-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with David Duchovny.
You've been here in the past
talking about
your work writing novels.
-Yeah.
-But this is your first graphic
novel, which is very exciting.
This sort of thing
is right up my alley.
-Yeah.
-Is it up yours, as well?
Is this something
you always thought --
[ Laughter ]
I don't know, guys.
-He's a professional!
-No, that was an accident.
It's just David
brings it out in me.
-That's like, "Did you see that
stuff b'low me?"
-Oh, my God. Stop it.
-Okay, I'm sorry.
-We're trying to sell
this cartoon.
-Cartoon?
-Cartoon. Now it's a cartoon.
It's a graphic novel.
[ Laughter ]
It's science fiction.
-Yes, it is.
-Was that something
you wanted to revisit?
-Not at all.
-Okay.
-No, I was trying to stay away
from that for so many years.
But it was -- You know,
if I have an idea, you know,
that idea will drive me
into the area where it lives.
So, I mean,
I had this kind of notion
after I read that book
"Sapiens."
Did you ever read that book?
-Yeah.
-Wonderful book. I recommend.
And, you know, just realizing
there were all these types of
hominids on this planet,
along with Homo sapiens,
along with our breed.
And what happened to them,
and why did we outcompete them?
"Outcompete" being another word
for eradicate them.
-Yeah.
-And so I thought,
"What about a fresh planet
where there were hominids?
And if we had the chance to be
stewards of that planet,
would we screw it up the way we
screwed up this planet?"
It's a comedy.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to say his name right.
Phillip Sevy?
-Sevy, yeah.
-So you're working with,
you know, an artist.
These are incredible
collaborations
when you do a comic like that.
Did you find it hard to sort of
write to the format?
-Yeah, it's very stringent.
There's not a lot of words.
As a novelist, I can kind of
luxuriate and spread out.
But, you know,
you get a little balloon.
You just get a balloon.
I was like,
"I need a bigger balloon!"
So, you get these balloons that
you got to fit the dialogue in
and fit, you know, the scene
descriptions in, so it's tough.
You got to be really economical.
-I will say, the really tough
part, with all due respect,
because I've been on
your side, as well --
I wrote one of these.
And then you write it,
and, again,
you have to be economical
and you take your time,
but then the artist really
has to do the hardest part.
And the fact that you
put it in their good hands --
And I don't know if you had
the same reaction that I've had
the same times I've had
something animated or drawn.
You cannot believe
how much more they add to it.
-Oh, I know, because,
well, first of all,
I can't even draw a stick
figure, so I'm just amazed.
But Phillip Sevy --
the big hurdle for us was,
on this planet Kepler,
which is a Goldilocks planet --
Do you know what that is?
It occupies a zone from the sun,
whatever sun it's orbiting,
that might sustain life.
Like, the Earth is a gold--
It's not too hot, not too cold.
Goldilocks.
-Ah, there we go.
-Yeah, got there.
-You got there.
-Whew! So, with this,
we had Neanderthals
or a type of Neanderthal
on this planet.
And we were always like,
"It can't be like a GEICO ad.
You know, we want it to be --
So, we spent a long time
figuring out the look,
which is not so different
from us Homo sapiens.
Neanderthals
are our close cousins.
So Phillip and I spent
many a time
just kind of figuring out like,
"What is that look
for the 'thal?"
is what we call them.
-The 'thals?
-Yeah, the 'thals.
Yeah, you like that?
-Yeah, it's great.
Because I don't think they had
slang back then, so...
And then, the last thing
I want to ask you --
you wrote a book
"Bucky [Bleep] Dent"
that you just then
directed a film of.
-Yes.
-How is it adapting
your own work?
-Oh, it was hellish, you know?
-Yeah.
-It's interesting.
I mean, you know, I've lived it.
It's in me for so long
that I felt like I knew it.
But Logan Marshall-Green,
who was the actor in the film --
he had read the book
while we were doing the movie.
And he would come to me
with stuff like,
"You should put this back in.
Why did you cut this out?"
And I was like,
"Yeah, that is really good.
Why did I cut that out?"
So then you start to
second-guess yourself, you know?
-Well, that will be very
exciting to see, as well.
-I'll come back
to talk about it.
-I hope so.
I'm always thrilled
to have you here.
Thanks so much for making
the time for us, as always.
-Thank you.
-"The Estate" is in theaters now
and on demand November 22nd.
And "Kepler"
is available December 27th.
We'll be right back with
Sarah Jones.